hello everyone and welcome to this
amazing video on prompt engineering by
simpl it was November 30 2022 Sam Alman
Greg Brockman and ilas AER would never
have thought that with the push off a
button they would completely alter the
lives of all human beings living on the
earth and of future generations to come
on November 30 the open AI team launched
Chad GB Chad G was born that day Alit a
very small event in the history of
Internet Evolution but one that can no
less be marked as one of the most
significant events of modern IT industry
chat GPD a text based chatbot that gives
replies to questions asked to it is
built on GPT large language model but
what was so different I mean the Google
search engine YouTube Firefox browser
they all have been doing the same for
decades so how is Chad gbt any different
and why is it such a big D well for
starters chat GPT was not returning
index websites that have been SEO tuned
and optimized to rank at the top chat
GPT was able to comprehend the nature
tone and the intent of the query asked
and generated text based responses based
on the questions asked it was like
talking to a chat bot on the internet
minus the out of context responses with
the knowledge of 1.7 trillion parameters
it was no shock that a Computing system
as efficient and prom test chat GPT
would have its own set bits so did Chad
GPT it was bound by the parameters of
the language model it was trained on and
it was limited to giving outdated
results since the last training data was
from September still Chad GP made Wales
in the tech community and continues to
do so just have a look at the Google
Trend search on Chad GP everyday new
content is being published on Chad gbt
and hundreds of AI tools the sheer
interest that individuals and
Enterprises across the globe has shown
in chat GPT and AI tools is immense ai
ai ai a a i generative AI generative AI
generative AI a ai ai ai a a a AI now
here comes the fun part jib or for that
matter any large language model runs on
neural networks trained on multi-million
billion and even trillions of data
parameters these chatbots generate
responses to user queries based on the
input given to it while it may generate
similar responses for identical or
similar queries it can also produce
different responses based on the
specific context phrasing and the
quality of input provided by each user
additionally chat GPT is designed to
adapt its language and tone to match the
style and preferences of each user so
its responses may varry in wording and
tone depending on the individual users
communication style and preferences
every user has their own unique style of
writing and communication and chat gut's
response can worry based on the input
given to it so this is where prompt
Engineers come into play prompt
engineers are expert at prompt
engineering sounds like a cyclic
definition right well let's break it
down first let's understand what prompts
are so prompts are any text based input
given to the model as a query this
includes statements like questions asked
the tone mentioned in the query the
context given for the query and the
format of output expected so here is a
quick example for your understanding now
that we have discussed what a prompt is
so let us now understand who is a prompt
engineer and why it has become the job
for the future broadly speaking a prompt
engineer is a professional who is
capable of drafting queries or prompts
in such a way that large language models
like GPT Palm llama Bloom Etc can
generate the response that is expected
these professionals are skilled at
crafting accurate and contextual prompts
which in turn allows the model to
generate desired results so here's a
quick example for you prompt Engineers
are experts not only at the linguistic
front but they also had extensive domain
knowledge and very well vered with the
functioning of neural networks and
natural language processing along with
the knowledge of scripting languages and
data analysis leading job platforms like
indeed and Linkedin already have many
prompt engineer positions in the United
States alone job postings for this role
run in the thousands reflecting the
growing demand the salary of prompt
Engineers is also compelling with a
range that spends from $50,000 to over
$150,000 per year depending on
experience and specialization so there
are multiple technical Concepts that a
prompt engineer must be well wored in to
be successful in their jobs such as
multimodality tokens weights parameters
Transformers to name a few whether it's
healthare defense IT services or attech
industry the need for skill prompt
Engineers is on the rise there are
already several thousand job openings in
this field and the demand will continue
to grow so if you want to hop on this
amazing opportunity and become an expert
prompt engineering professional then now
is the time let us know in the comments
what you think about prompt engineering
and if you want to know more about the
skills needed to become a prompt
engineer then make sure to like and
share this video with your friends and
family and tell them about this amazing
new job opportunity also subscribe to
our channel so that you never miss out
on the amazing Tech videos we make just
for you staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here